okay on to the next game
titico grand master from mexico i played
him a couple of times already and
i was pretty much surprised that some
choices he made pretty
unconventional player at some point
i have only a very
vague knowledge about this i must admit
of course usually um black goes for the
quick pawn storm with f4
but i also saw this idea once
i'm not sure maybe it is entirely too
slow but
it still looks interesting i guess one
problem here could be a quick opening of
the position with f4 at some point
okay on this check he has the
retreat
and then the check looks pretty
ridiculous
well maybe but
still there's the f5 i haven't played
f4 check
i take on e4 now
what what what is he doing on this move
if he takes on e4 no i i can simply take
on e4
with i think a deadly pin and
what what move for white now
this one okay
can i do something radical here
like inserting e3 or something
i don't think it's enough
okay what about
e e3 at this point
where does he go if he plays knight d3 i
can
i can take
i can simply take i think
and now the knight to f5 this shouldn't
be too bad
okay so
knight is what about 93 this isn't a
problem
yeah well i already played a couple of
games
against him and i never got any of these
moves so
even if he's a grandmaster for whatever
reason he plays really strange moves
so queen c7 what is this i've got an
extra rooker
well he just played played awful i think
this is still a normal position of
course but
this simply is not not playable
i could also maybe take on e4 just but
okay now queen to b6 was was fine
i i think maybe one needs to
to look for some way to to play f4 in
this position i still
think no idea it's it's
maybe it's still a theoretical position
and as
i don't know